So our current widget focuses on
one thing, today's weather, and
I'm kind of okay with that.
However, there are certainly times when
quick access to the entire forecast
would be helpful.
For that case,
we can build a collection widget.
These widgets control full list, grid,
or stack of elements, perfect for
showing off the upcoming forecast.
Good starting point for
this is a simple list view widget.
The top banner can open Sunshine itself,
while below the list offers
direct access to the forecast
of each upcoming day.
Clicking on one of these will
go directly to the detail
page for that day.
So, I'll layout style and header click
behavior the same as our today widget.
Filling in the data on our list
here is a different story.
For that,
we'll use a remote view service.
The remote view service is responsible
for creating a RemoteViewsFactory.
Think of it as the equivalent to
a cursor adapter, that's specifically
designed for returning remote views,
suitable for widgets.
Note the special permission,
BIND_REMOTEVIEWS.
This is what let's the system
bind your service to
create your remote views for each row.
To tell our remote views to
connect to our RemoteViewsFactory,
you'll use
the setRemoteViewsAdaptors method.
This method kicks of
the RemoteViewsFactory's life cycle,
causing our data to reload and
remote views created for each row.
To update our widget based on new data,
we can still use the same
technique as our Today widget,
in receiving the data updated broadcast.
But instead of calling an Intent Service
to update the whole widget,
we can just call the
NotifyAppWidgetViewDataChanged method
to trigger the onDataSetChanged
three queries for new data.
So if that's all it takes to
get data into our widget, and
get out list populated,
we're done right?
In some cases, sure.
But we're trying to make
this production ready.
What we really want is to be able
to tap on a particular day and
go directly to the details of that date.
If your mind is already spinning on
where to add the set on click pending
intent method to get this working,
you'll be happy to know that there's
some tools which make this easier.
The idea is that each element
shares some common template for
the click action.
That means our app widget provider can
also call setPendingIntentTemplate
with the pending intent that
has all the common attributes.
Say, what activity to start.
Our RemoteViewsFactory get you at
method then handles the unique part for
each element calling set
on click fill in intent
to fill in our template appropriately.
Now of course, for Sunshine,
we have to consider how about tablet's,
which have the master and
detail view together and phones, which
have them as separate activities, work.
That complicates things a bit here.
Let's just see how it
all falls together.